after she reviews together
they wanted me to apologize for saying
the word pocahontas
so no no i apologize to pocahontas to
the real one
[Applause]
no no she you wouldn't get out and she
took enough votes away and biden won
super tuesday that shouldn't happen but
if
i don't sound like a typical washington
politician fortunately that's because
i'm not a politician
but think of it you know you're talking
about politician no fracking for a year
and a half right
and then he goes to pennsylvania says no
no they'll be fracking
like nothing happened can you imagine if
i did that no parking no fracking no
fracking i'm the opposite by the way no
braking no fracking
then you win and you go you know got to
go a little
to the other direction a little bit to
the right although he actually went
further left which is sort of an amazing
thing but all of a sudden it comes
out in favor of fracking and let me tell
you it's always the first thing that
turns out to be true
okay they will lose you will lose in
pennsylvania a million jobs there will
be no petroleum products
there will be no fracking whatsoever and
did you see his party and i was really
angry at him because he's saying maybe
they'll be fracking
it's a very conditional you know it's a
very weak but with me
you're gonna frack you're gonna fret
and you're going to keep your energy low
and we're independent you know we are
now energy independent first time
ever so if i don't always play by the
rules of the washington establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you and i fought harder for you than any
president has ever fought for their
people right now i'm fighting to
eradicate the virus rebuild the economy
and save our country
from the radical left and that's a big
thing saving it because these people
this will end up being a large scale
version
of venezuela if they get in they don't
have water
they don't have medicine they don't have
food they don't have anything
despite everything they've thrown at us
we've done more in the first three and a
half years than any administration in
history
and the best is yet to come
a recent gallup poll just came out
thank you a gallup poll just
came out they found that 56 of americans
say they're better off today
than they were under sleepy joe and
obama
it's the highest of any president at
this point in this term
think of that 56 this is as we round the
corner on the pandemic 56
they were much much lower just remember
this
if they were any good i wouldn't have
run for president but they were no good
they did a horrible job
they did a horrible job yesterday biden
told those
56 of americans that they probably
shouldn't vote for him
and for once i agree with joe did you
hear he said you shouldn't vote for me
you know he has no idea what he's saying
how the hell do you lose to a guy like
this is this possible
oh i'll never come to pennsylvania again
i love this one
you know they say he was born in
scranton but he left
he left he abandoned you he said give me
a break
thank you i love you
thank you thank you thank you
by the way this is a lot of people here
tonight
a lot of people i wish the fake news
would show it they never turn
the cameras you know i go home
our great first lady always says how was
the crowd
i said didn't they show no that you show
your face
and about five people behind me right
they become famous
[Applause]
why don't you show the crowd though why
don't you do yourself a favor show the
crowd
one of the most important issues for
pennsylvania is the survival of your
fracking industry
joe biden has repeatedly pledged to
abolish fracking he's a liar
okay he's a liar how do you do it
how do you do it he went for a year and
a half they said are you
remember the debates with the radical
left democrats right
you had uh alfred newman you had all
these people
you know who alfred newman is yes pete
budac
pete budac he's a bad mayor of a failed
town and he's going to run for president
you know
pete boudicek but you know uh he's
talking about it
and does that mean everybody nobody
is going to do right that's right nobody
nobody else where nobody nobody nobody
then he gets up i've never seen anything
like it in my life and not one fake
reporter back there
said well wait a minute you've been
pledging for a year and a half no
fracking but then what about the uh
health care for illegal immigrants
who in this group is going to provide
health care for illegal immigrants
everybody raises their hand you remember
joe
no do you remember this is a famous clip
but they don't ask them questions about
it because they're fake
you remember joe who's going to provide
and look we all have hearts
and we want to take care of everybody
but you know the problem when you do
that
we don't have the money the whole world
is going to empty out into our country
they're going to come for
health care they're going to come for a
college free college
i say sometimes jokingly sarcastically
everybody gets a free rolls royce
to which cnn says they don't get a free
rolls royce he has misrepresented
you know these people are sick
everybody gets a free rolls royce they
don't get a free roast
the president has misrepresented ah they
are sick people but think of it so
remember when joe and
they said raise your hand if everybody's
in favor of
free everything free everything but free
health care for
illegal aliens and joe goes like
he had no idea what the hell he was
doing folks he has no clue
and he's not a nice guy you know just so
you understand not a nice guy
if he was a nice guy i wouldn't hit him
like this but he's not a nice guy he's a
bad guy
he's always been a dummy but he's always
been he's never been
no no in his best of years he was
considered a dumb guy
when asked about fracking biden said
he would sure absolutely make it
we will uh eliminate it
that's what he said those are the exact
words and then he said it 19 different
times and one day he said
i never said that it's incredible and
they don't question them
i couldn't get away with it for a minute
not for a minute did you see the town
hall he had with nbc
that was a town hall for a child a young
child
barron trump would actually baron's far
too advanced for that town
that was a town hall lester holt
lester holt that was a beauty right that
was some town hall that was
and they said yes we have a random
sampling of people yeah all trump haters
right what a group of people but he
raised his hand he said
illegal immigrants will get health care
now people don't realize what that means
that means your
social security goes down the tubes your
country goes bankrupt you know
the whole thing is a disaster but he
raised his hand
now he's trying to say he didn't do it
and they don't call him out because
they're fake his radical left running
mate
who i just watched on television she's
so pathetic
is a co-sponsor of the socialist green
new deal
which eliminates all fossil fuels
she's having a hard time getting out of
that one did you hear the other day she
actually
came out in favor of frackie and it was
like yeah i think so
she's further left than bernie did you
see bernie
i thought was the furthest left of the
senate because you don't get too much
worse right
then you go instead of socialist you go
to the c word right
she's further left she's considered
further left
than bernie this is and you know they're
looking when nancy pelosi does the 25th
amendment she's doing it for biden you
do know that right
because they want to get biden out and
that won't be hard
but at this very moment's website
you have more doctors than you thought
existed in the world
i was surrounded with like 14 of them
where are you from i'm from this one
where are you from i'm from
johns hopkins i'm from walter reed but
what great talented people they did a
great job
and thank you and while i'm president
america will remain the world's number
one
energy producer with pennsylvania
workers leading the way
and that's what's happening you're
leading the way
you know you had the best year in the
history of your your
place it's a history of if you look at
the commonwealth of pennsylvania you
never want to say state don't ever say
state
actually nobody cares about them but you
know
i'm just saying let's see pennsylvania
you got two of them you know that right
the commonwealth the great commonwealth
of pennsylvania i went to school here
probably spent more time here than
sleepy joe and all four
i went to school here but we're putting
our great coal miners back to work joe
biden and the democrat socialists will
kill your jobs
dismantle your police departments you
see that happening
and we've got did you see in the debate
the other night i said to him
name one law enforcement agency just one
in a whole country
that supports you he couldn't do it then
chris wallace bailed him out
then i say how come you got the three
and a half million from russia
and they bailed him out again he was
choking like a dog they bailed him out
but they want to dissolve your borders
they don't want borders they want to
have open borders release
criminal aliens raise your taxes
confiscate
your guns get rid of your second
amendment
[Applause]
i mean here's one that's incredible
destroy your suburbs okay so they talk
about the suburban women
and somebody said i don't know if the
suburban woman
likes you i say why but we had this
i love you too
[Applause]
they said they may not like the way you
talk but i'm about law and order i'm
about
having you safe i'm about having your
suburban communities
i i don't want to build low-income
housing next to your house okay if
that's okay
and i ended the regulation the rule that
made the zoning so
impossible that you had to destroy your
communities and then i hear the suburban
woman
i think that the suburban woman and i
used to say
suburban housewife i used to take heat
but i said does anybody care do you care
if i say suburban no they're all gone no
again the only one cares is them trump
said suburban housewife but i didn't say
it
because i don't you learn very quickly
you learn very quickly
but suburban women they should like me
more than anybody here tonight
because i ended the regulation
that destroyed your neighborhood i ended
the regulation that brought crime to the
suburbs
and you're going to live the american
dream and that's what you're going to do
and remember this 29
of the people experiencing the american
dream in the suburbs happen to be
minority and you don't know that but 29
and we're doing this for everybody we're
not doing it one way or the other we're
doing
it and i ended it they said sir we can
amend it i said i don't want to amend it
i want to end it it was a horror show
and this loser corey booker is the guy
that's going to be in charge of the
program the guy's a stone-cold loser one
percent
he got one percent he ran he was gonna
be great you know one percent
every week he was like her down down
down they should have picked him
but no he'll be in charge of your uh
suburban so can
i ask you to do me a favor suburban
women will you please let me
please please i saved your damn
neighborhood okay
the other thing i don't have that much
time to be that nice you know i can do
it but i gotta go
quickly we don't have time they want me
to be politically correct oh
yes let's discuss it let's talk about it
over the next 10 years no no no
now we saved your we saved suburbia
in the u.s i got rid of a regulation
that was a disaster
and it was very unfair and you've been
reading about it for a long time it's
been going on for a long time
it became much worse under obama and
biden
i got rid of it and i had a choice am i
even my own people said
you never get rid of it sir i said i
want to get rid of it well what are we
just amended
i said i don't want to amend it i want
to get rid of it get rid of it
okay and i think we're going to see that
the women really like trump a lot that's
happened last time remember
remember last four years ago four years
ago they said women will never vote for
him i said why am i so bad
they say the women will never vote then
i got 52 they said what the hell
happened with the women
except this time see this is much easier
because then i was a developer i was
doing great everything was nice but i
had never done this before
i came in i said i'm going to rebuild
our military i'm going to cut your taxes
i'm going to cut your regulations i'm
going to get you this i'm going to get
you that i'm going to take care of our
vets
i mean i did things that frankly i never
even talked about like space force
i never talked about space work the wall
is almost built
you know the wall is up to 392 miles
it's almost and mexico is paying for the
wall by the way you know that i've been
saying it
they hate to hear that but they're
paying you know we're putting a charge
on where the cars go through
and it'll more than pay for the wall but
uh we have now the most secure
southern border that we've ever had and
i want to thank the president of mexico
they have 27
000 mexican soldiers on our southern
border stopping people from coming into
the u.s
illegally thank you very much
[Applause]
no but we did all these things so this
time in theory it should be easier
but don't forget i've gone through years
years
of a fake witch hunt and now it turned
out that they were the guilty party
they were the ones dealing with russia
they were the guilty people
think if i didn't have every night on
that fake cnn right over there with a
light on
the light just went off just every time
i point to them the light goes off it's
all right keep it off
nobody's watching them anyway but you
know
think if i didn't have every night
russia russia russia hey
and nobody's been tougher in russia than
me what i've done for nato
raised a hundred and thirty billion
dollars a year from other countries
that weren't paying their bills they
were delinquent as we said in the real
estate business they were delinquent
and that goes up to 410 billion dollars
nobody did that
obama used to send them pillows maybe
from the pillow man on fox
did you ever see a man advertised so
much i've never seen it
i've never seen the biggest advertiser i
think he's the greatest advertising
genius mike
he's the greatest entrance if i gave him
our budget you wouldn't be able to do
anything else but watch
trump ads the pillow man i tell you i
never saw so many ads in my life every
day it's a pillow the pillow
now he came out with a sheet and i'm
going crazy that's all
that's all we need now is a new sheet
but he's on our side too by the way that
guy he's on our side
mike
[Applause]
and now biden even refuses to answer
questions unpacking the supreme court
you know elections have consequences
winning and losing an election
that's big consequences and we've been
winning elections
and they say well you know trump
shouldn't be appointing the new justice
because well i'm president
in fact as you know a lot of your great
justices said no no
they're appointed justice ginsburg just
said
recently not so long ago no no
he's president for four years not for
three years
your point now he was she was referring
to obama
i think or clinton or somebody
but wasn't referring to me i can promise
you that
oh don't worry don't worry it's being
filmed it's me
you don't have to worry about that
that's much easier than we'll build a
wall that goes
that goes for a lot that's what you know
the wall is one of the biggest projects
in the history of this country you know
that right
and we had a party dedicated to the
proposition
that there will never ever be a wall
that will never they knew it was the
right thing to do
and i made one big mistake i should have
come instead of saying we will build a
wall i should have said we will never
ever build a wall they would have given
me so much money
made a big mistake oh great congressman
over there
are you guys having a good time by the
way huh mike
he said the voters don't deserve to know
and he'll tell you after the election
what he's gonna do and you know what i
did i gave you a list i have 45 people
on that list every one of them's a star
and i gave you a list yeah sit down
everybody just enjoy yourself what the
hell
look at these people i didn't even
realize you're all standing
i didn't realize you had seats you're
lucky this is one of the few crowds we
provided seats that's because it's
pennsylvania i guess
it's pretty good if they win democrats
will pack the supreme court with radical
left justices
who will shred your second amendment you
can forget about
guns empower violent mobs and shield
deadly criminals and terrorists
to defend our constitution from this
madness i proudly nominated
judge amy coney barrett of the united
states supreme court
and to the court she'll be a great
justice
of the united states supreme court she's
done so well
i really found it fascinating to that
you know i don't have too much time i
tried to watch as much as i could she
was great
the radical left is hell bent on
destroying everything we love and
cherish
they're enraged and unhinged and they
are going crazy
you know think of it very many you know
presidents never have anybody to
appoint i will have by the end of the
first term almost
300 federal judges and
three supreme court justices
their heads are exploding i hope they're
happy
they want to cancel you shame you and
persecute you that's what they want to
do they want to shame in
this whole cancel culture thing you know
now they're after abraham lincoln they
don't like abraham lincoln
no he wasn't too good was i said this
three years ago remember
when they took down a couple of statues
of people you never heard of a
confederate soldier somebody else
somebody i said oh really
the next will be robert e lee the next
will be abraham lincoln
the next will be george washington and
everybody laughed they said oh
the president is so funny i said i'm not
being funny
these people are sick these people they
want to take away your heritage
and by the way are there any italians in
the room
okay well we are protecting
the legacy of christopher columbus okay
you know the italians are tough i love
the italians so they were going to rip
down the statue of christopher columbus
in new york you saw that right
and all of a sudden a group of italians
circled around the statue and they were
having pretty tough things in their hand
i must say
and it was amazing how those people that
wanted to rip it down disappeared very
quickly so the italians let me tell you
christopher columbus will always be here
on my watch that i can tell you
[Applause]
now i had people the other day that
wanted to wish me happy columbus day
they were afraid i said why are you
ashamed no no say it
happy christopher columbus day this is
christopher columbus day it's columbus
day
okay so italian say thank you mr
president i appreciate i like you too i
love the italians they want to punish
the middle class
expunge every last trace of traditional
values and replace
the american dream with the socialist
nightmare and that's what would happen
just take a look at what's going on in
other parts of the world biden's agenda
not that he has one but you know
he does whatever they tell him to do he
got so lucky
she should have she should have gotten
out you know she was faithful she would
have gotten out bernie would have run we
would have been running against crazy
bernie instead
but i'd rather run against joe because
there's no enthusiasm there's no energy
one thing with bernie's people
and you know we got a lot of people last
time from bernie
because they love me on trade because
they know our country has been
ripped off on trade like no country has
ever been ripped off and bernie's people
get that
and they uh they like us on trade
biden's agenda would be
a catastrophe for seniors for years
biden tried to
cut social security and medicare nobody
remembers that
and the press will never bring it up but
he tried to cut
your social security right now by does
pledging mass amnesty and federal health
care for the illegal aliens decimating
medicare and destroying your social
security
biden cares more about illegal aliens
and he cares about your senior citizens
and it's true
and let me just tell you this and i say
it strongly and when i first got elected
they always played the social security
card
and nothing happened right your social
security now is better than ever i
haven't touched it
while i am president no one will touch
your medicare or your social security
under my leadership we're delivering a
safe vaccine and a rapid recovery if you
vote for me
prosperity will surge normal life that's
what we want normal life
we want normal life we'll fully resume
and next year will be one of the
greatest economic years in the history
of our country
it's already happening how about the
stock market
who has 401ks in the audience so well
i can tell you one thing i'm getting all
of your votes
i'm getting your votes your 401ks are
setting records
think of it as we're rounding the turn
and we are they go crazy when i say
we're rounding the turn on the pandemic
we understand that hey i just had it
here i am you know it's me it's actually
me
and i could have stayed in the basement
of the white house or maybe the top
floor of the white house i could have
done that but i'm the president of the
united states i can't do that
i gotta get out and i have to meet
people and i have to see people
and i know it's risky to do that but you
have to do what you have to do you know
i'm the president i can't sit in the
basement and say let's wait this thing
out
i'm not gonna do that and now i'm immune
they tell me i'm immune i could come
down and start kissing everybody
i'll kiss every guy man and woman man
and woman look at that guy how handsome
he is
i'll kiss him not not with a lot of
enjoyment but that's okay
joe biden would terminate our recovery
delay the vaccine
prolong the pandemic and annihilate the
economy with draconian unscientific
lockdowns like you're having right
now in pennsylvania with this governor
who is killing you
tom wolf tom wolf come on tom
open up pennsylvania tom open it up
you know what's going to happen november
4th they'll open it up you know that
they're doing it they want to keep the
numbers as
bad as possible here's the problem the
numbers are going to come out just
before
the election so we have november 3rd the
numbers are going to come out and
pennsylvania's a late voting state you
actually believe in going to a poll
because you see all the shenanigans no
you're a late voting state
and all i can tell you is when i came
here and i said this before but when i
came here i promise you a lot of things
i've done much more than i promised you
you had the best year you've ever had
and you're going to have a better year
next year
you damn well better vote for me
pennsylvania
sleepy joe biden's plan will crush
america
and my plan we're going to crush the
virus very quickly it's happening
already it's happening
almost 90 percent less mortality you
know the the mortality rate
is at like 85. if you had it seven or
eight months ago it was not as good
as if you have it now and soon it's
gonna be perfecto
and uh i said that the drug that they
gave me
i'm gonna we're going to be distributing
it all over the country to hospitals and
everything else
because i'll tell you that sucker works
that's my opinion
what do i know but to me it works and
and the people that did it they're
phenomenal people they've had great
success with other vaccines and drugs
just this week we learned that another
member of the biden family is getting
rich
off connections to joe his son-in-law
just came out big story is cashing in on
the china virus pandemic
just like hunter where's hunter crashed
in on china
what do you think where hunter walks in
and he walks out with a billion and a
half dollars to manage for china
i said to a friend of mine one of the
biggest guys on wall street does that
ever happen he said
i'm the biggest guy on wall street that
doesn't happen for me
10 minutes he had a billion and a half
dollars maybe he's not so stupid after
all
to fight the china virus we launched the
largest mobilization since world
war ii and we really should get credit
for what we've done because i'll tell
you mike pence
and all of these people they have worked
so 24 hours around the clock
our early and aggressive action saved as
many as 2 million lives remember when
they said no no no you don't want to ban
china don't ban china
i did it in january they were talking a
month and a half later we shouldn't be
doing it he called me xenophobic
i said joe give me a definition of
xenophobic please he was unable to do
that
we pioneered life-saving therapies and
reduced the fatality rate
by 85 percent i'm working with the fda
to make the antibody treatments i
received and everybody we're going to
have them
they're going to be shipped very soon
we're working on an emergency
use authorization very complicated stuff
and the fda has never responded
like they've responded to me this could
have taken years
what we've done and we've done it in
weeks
i know they came to me on one thing and
they said sir will that will take
approximately two and a half years i
said no it's no good when do you need it
sir
next week tomorrow how about tomorrow
now we're pushing them hard the fda has
been great to everyone fighting to
recover from the virus
i feel your pain because i felt your
pain
and we will beat this virus together
and for those who has had it who has had
it here who's had it
yeah a lot of people a lot of people
you're the people i want to say hello to
because you are right now immune
you're right now immune or they say that
you know they hate to admit it because i
had it so in the old days they said well
if you have it you're immune for life
right
once i got it they give you four months
they say you're a book
you know is anybody else but me you're
immune for life
through operation warp speed which is
incredible will
have 100 million vaccine doses before
the end of this year 100 million
and the vaccine will end the pandemic
once and for all
and remember this because i have the
endorsement of i think every major law
enforcement and minor
law enforcement group in the country
[Applause]
we have a lot of democrats that left
their party and they came over law
enforcement people
i can almost tell you by looking look at
this group over here
i know the law enforcement people
nobody's been better
we had all the surplus military
equipment obama didn't want to give it
out because he said
it looked too militaristic i said no i
want to save lives
okay it's defensive equipment i want to
save lives and
we gave out hundreds of millions of uh
it was sitting in warehouses all over
the country military equipment
and we gave it out but there's nobody
like the great men
and women of law enforcement
but this election is also about look at
that whoa
whoa see they love you
see that wow i didn't expect that
that's pretty good
that's great
but this election is about law and order
you look at portland
we keep saying to the governor look
governor oregon i said governor
let us go and we'll solve the problem in
30 minutes they don't want to do that
you know they're supposed to ask you to
come
in we did a great job in minnesota
minneapolis except you know
instead of 10 days they could have
called us like two hours later
but they came in and they lined up and
they were not socially distanced
they lined up you saw that they came in
wearing black uniforms 250 000
most expensive uniforms i never saw so
many computers on a helmet
but they went in and they had their tear
gas so they had their pepper spray which
the other side doesn't want us to use
anymore they said no
we don't want to do that these people
are a lot of bad people out there you
know they're anarchists
radical left anarchists okay so
they came in they came in you saw it
there was one person i said where the
rest then another
one then another one then i started
getting off buses wherever they
all of a sudden you had one line two
line and they just started moving
forward that was the end of the problem
it ended within 30 minutes it was over
it was over
and we'll do it wherever they want us
would love to go into portland because
those guys are bad news we actually
you saw we sent in the us marshals right
because uh one man
horrible guy shot somebody right through
it ahead
shot him in the middle of the street a
guy who didn't wasn't hurting anybody
he killed him two days went by three
days went by said why the hell haven't
they arrested him and they knew who he
was
and we sent in the u.s marshals and in
15 minutes it was all over
that was the end of it that was the end
of it
biden harris and the democrat party
declared war on our police okay and
we've proudly received the endorsement
of the national association of police
organizations
the national troopers coalition the
international
union of police associations the
pennsylvania state troopers association
[Applause]
the wow order of police including those
in philadelphia pittsburgh scranton and
virtually every single police
organization
[Music]
and during the debate i asked sleepy joe
i said give me
one organization law enforcement that's
endorsing you and he couldn't do it
then chris wallace saved him then i said
remember i said
so tell me say the words law and order
say it joe say it
he couldn't do it he wouldn't do it he
wouldn't do it because you know what
because he'd be run out of his party if
he said the words law and order
then i think at the end didn't he say
like law and order and safety and
justice and you know all the stuff
no no law and order say law and order
joe he couldn't do it
so we're joined tonight by some real
warriors warriors of a different type
political warriors they're okay too
right
and they're friends of mine they're
great people representative john
joyce john please
[Applause]
a guy's been around a long time and he
fights like hell
gt thompson gt thank you
great be careful with your election i
hear you're only up 40 points gt
another one was only up about 44 points
a really good friend of mine and as
tough as hell
mike kelly
i say gt mike you need any help i'll
come and help you in your district
no sir we don't really need help don't
worry about it
a friend of mine and a great gentleman
and he was the first one that
did that i was gonna win this thing i'll
tell you former congressman
lou barletta thank you
thank you lou how are we doing lil are
we doing okay
how do we compare to four years ago
better okay good he said the right thing
anyway yeah i think a lot better because
we produced
again four years ago i said we're going
to do things now we've done them all
plus additional things i mean a lot of
additional things i never talked about
space first we did space wars
you know somebody did space force that's
like
a major achievement for four years
that's one thing that's like one thing
out of so many other things so it's one
of those things but i never used to talk
about that
and former chair of the pennsylvania
republican party a friend of mine the
guy that knows more about pennsylvania
than any human being on earth
robbed lisa rob thank you
[Applause]
how we doing rob good okay
good he said to me another group came
down they didn't want his advice
they came down from boston and they put
events all over the place and he said
you go in the wrong location anyway they
ended up losing big right
but with us we came to rob we say where
do you think the best places are and we
hit
and we agreed with you too but rob
gleason's been a fantastic friend thank
you rob very much for being here
appreciate it
and with their help and your help we are
delivering
for the american people like never
before nobody's ever done what we've
done in three and a half years no
administration's ever done this the
first three and a half years
in my first three years in office family
income increased by
six thousand dollars and that doesn't
include energy
which i think is you could double it up
more than five
times the gains in all eight years
of the obama administration
african-american income grew nine times
more
than it did under the last
administration think of it african
american
income grew nine not two
not three nine times more
and these are out of the book
these numbers are out of the book real
wealth for the bottom 50 percent grew
nearly twice as fast as it grew for the
top
1 hispanic family net worth increased by
64 in a short period of time 64.
we added nearly 600 000 manufacturing
jobs and we added 15 000 factories
and obama said you'll never produce
manufacturing jobs remember
you need a magic wand well we found the
magic wand
we lifted 6.6 million americans out of
poverty including over 1 million
african americans and more than 1.5
million
hispanic americans and we're doing great
with both groups and we love them
we love both groups thank you those are
great numbers
after our tax cuts took effect wages for
the lowest income americans grew twice
as fast
as those near the top think of that you
never hear that stuff
the big beneficiary we're lowest income
americans my policies have benefited
those who need it the most
after the virus came in from china and
we had a change
we had to do things this came out it was
a sudden
horrible thing china should have never
ever
let it happen they should have never let
it happen we've seen the smallest
economic contraction of any major
western nation by far
and we've seen by far the fastest
recovery
of any nation
in the past five months we've created a
record 11.4
million jobs that's american jobs that's
the fastest
ever recorded job growth has been
23 times faster than the first five
months think of this
in the first five months of the obama
biden recovery
23 times we cut unemployment rate in
half
under biden it took 30 months to recover
more than
half the jobs lost in the crisis we did
it in five months
so we're talking about numbers that
nobody can even believe home builder
confidence
has reached an all-time high we're in a
pandemic
reached an all-time high manufacturing
optimism
has doubled consumer confidence which
just came out
has surged nearly 20 percent and small
business confidence is now higher than
any time
in the entire decade preceding my
election think of that
and we're rounding the turn on a
pandemic
we've spent the last four years
reversing the damage
joe biden inflicted over the last 47
years he made every bad deal in the book
and by the way if you look at the h1 n1
you know he calls it the n1h one right i
said no
here's the no h remember joe h comes
beforehand
he goes the n1 h1 whatever it's called
what was his name again or the senator
or maybe he was a governor yeah romney
romney oh that's right it was romney
it's amazing you know amazing and he
gets away with that stuff
you only see it you know you only see it
on the internet they never report it
they never report it they should report
it they're doing
this country a great disservice by not
reporting it but biden supported nafta
tpp and china's entry into the wto which
is one of the worst
things that ever happened to this
country for half a century biden twisted
his blade into the heart of the american
worker
he should not be asking for your votes
he should be begging for your
forgiveness he did a rotten job okay
did a rotten job for decades our
politicians spent trillions and
trillions of dollars
rebuilding foreign nations fighting
foreign wars
and defending foreign borders but now
we're finally protecting our nation
rebuilding our cities and we are
bringing our
jobs our factories and our troops
back home to the usa where they belong
almost done syria were gone except we
kept the oil does anybody mind that i
kept the oil
so we left some troops behind to keep
the oil
with iraq we're almost out with
afghanistan 19 years in afghanistan 19
years
and uh we're really serving as policemen
it's great to be policemen but they they
got to have their own policemen
they got to do it themselves but we're
uh we're bringing them home we're down
to a very few number of soldiers
to save our auto industry i withdrew
from the last administration's
trans-pacific
partnership disaster it would have been
a disaster it would have destroyed your
automobile
industry and others to defend our steel
and aluminum workers i
imposed historic tariffs on dumped goods
remember when they were dumping steel
all over the place you guys were getting
killed
saving those industries from total
destruction
and frankly had the plague not came in
from china but now they're doing well
anyway had that come in you would have
had a steel industry that would have
been at a level that nobody's ever seen
before
but it came in but you're going to be
there anyway in a short period of time
unless some
stupid person comes along and raises
your taxes by four times what they
should be
which is what they want to do i ended
the nafta nightmare and signed the brand
new usmca
into law everyone said that was going to
be impossible
and i withdrew from the job-killing
paris climate accord
so nice of them to tell us that we can't
use our energy
i was at a court you know what i was
going to do destroy our country that's
what that was going to do pi
if you look at what has happened over
the last very short period of time the
progress that this nation has made
you're not even going to believe it and
you're going to see it and you would
have seen it had to plague that come in
because it was all happening
we were at every single record but now
we're getting close anyway the jobs are
all coming back and the market is almost
going to be topping the market
from before the plague and it's pretty
amazing i will tell you
biden is vowed to rejoin this horrible
agreement
a death sentence for your state's energy
industry the paris accord it's a
terrible thing unlike biden i know my
job is to represent
pennsylvania not paris we're
representing pennsylvania not paris
[Applause]
got a lot of nice people that can
represent paris
i took the toughest ever action to
confront
china's rap and theft of american jobs
you know that
we charged them so much we gave a lot of
the money to our farmers 28 billion
dollars to our farmers
because our farmers were targeted
everybody get your money they did better
without even growing anything to be
honest
but we got it from china 28 billion we
had a lot left over that went into the
treasury of the united states
to defend american workers earlier today
i also signed an order to crack down on
chinese counterfeiters and merchants
who sell their fake products all over
the united states
they put the name tiffany tiffany he's
got the blue box everything tiffany
tiffany tiffany isn't that wonderful but
it wasn't made
by tiffany biden will eliminate my
tariffs on china he's already said he's
going to take the tariffs off china
there goes your steel industry there
goes your aluminum industry there goes
everything
allowing them to plunder without
consequence
the one constant and biden's platform is
surrender he surrenders
he surrenders whether it's uh china
whether it's cuba
how about cuba how about the deal they
made with cuba how bad was that one
i ended it that's why both china and the
far left
are desperate for a biden win because he
will surrender our jobs to china
china will own the united states
if that sleepy guy gets the position
okay
and you can forget about pennsylvania
and you know don't also forget your
streets will be surrendered to the mob
you know
republican areas are great they're doing
great
the crime is at record lows everything
else these are the democrats super
liberal democrat areas
unlike sleepy joe biden i will never
abandon our nation
and i will never abandon its values
my goal is not to make friends in the dc
swamp my goal is to fight
for you and fight for your family
in 2017 i proudly signed a historic
executive order
making an official government policy to
buy american
and hire americans
[Applause]
my opponent has put forward a radical
plan to eliminate u.s
borders by implementing catch and
release programs that i ended
you know what catcher releases you catch
a murderer
you catch a rapist coming across our
border and you release them catch
catch them and release them and you say
i'm sorry three years from now please
come back for a court case
nobody comes back imposing deadly
sanctuary cities and suspending
all removals they don't want any
removals this is what biden agreed to
with crazy bernie sanders
when you have people that are in this
country illegally even if they're
murderers
if they're rapists no matter what they
are
you can't remove them we've removed tens
of thousands of people including ms-13
it would mean the total nullification of
u.s borders
overwhelming every city in town in
america and especially in a place
like pennsylvania biden wins your
borders are gone
which means your health care is gone the
middle class is gone
and your safety is gone other than that
you'll be doing very nicely
under my leadership we achieved the most
secure border in u.s history
and we're finishing that wall it's going
to be built very soon it's going to be
finished we're going to have the
greatest celebration
that was a tough one that was a tough
one remember
they said we don't need a wall they
wanted drones you know drones flying
around
looking at the people pouring across the
border they wanted drones they wanted
modern technology you know what i've
said often right
there are two things that will always be
around in a thousand years
in 2000 years all new computers all new
everything you know you come up with a
new computer you come up with a new chip
three days later it's obsolete i would
not want to be in that business but
there are two things
a wall and a wheel right a wall and a
wheel in a thousand years two thousand
years it's going to be here
we invested 2.5 trillion dollars in the
u.s military and launched
the first new branch of the united
states armed forces in more than 75
years
space force for our great vets
we passed va choice and va
accountability nobody thought would ever
get that done
we killed the leader of isis
al-baghdadi
[Applause]
and we took down 100 of the isis
caliphate
and when i took over that caliphate was
all over the place
it was a mess we took out the world's
number one terrorist
and the mass murder of many american
troops many troops many people all over
the world
kasim sulaimani is dead
thank you he's dead i withdrew from the
last administration's disastrous iran
nuclear deal one of the worst deals i've
ever seen
that's john kerry the guy was totally
incompetent that guy didn't know what
the hell he was doing
he gave him 150 billion dollars 1.8
billion in cash for
nothing i kept my promise
recognized the true capital of israel
and opened the american embassy in
jerusalem
[Applause]
i also recognize israeli sovereignty
over the golan heights
52 years they've been trying to get that
and instead of endless war we're forging
peace in the middle east you see the
deals we met i actually got
nominated for a nobel peace prize the
press didn't cover it
i got nominated for three nobel peace
prizes
i did more in 47 months than joe biden
did in 47 years and that's true
now biden is pushing the most far left
agenda ever put forward by a
presidential nominee
he's going to ruin your energy he's
going to ruin your state
the biden plan would destroy social
security
and destroy protections for pre-existing
conditions because there's no money
biden's running mate sponsored a bill to
outlaw
private health insurance we have 180
million people
with great private plans they want to
keep it that way
they're going to outlaw they're going to
get rid of them biden vowed to terminate
our travel bans on jihadist regions
and surged refugee admissions by more
than 700
he agreed to this he said that's okay
let him come in you know i got the ban
right remember the ban
remember it was a big deal i got the ban
i said if it's okay we have unfriendly
countries if it's already with you
they're not coming into our country i
got the ban we won in the
supreme court five to four i got the ban
he wants to give up the ban he wants to
let people pour into a country
700 increase opening the floodgates to
radical islamic terrorism
i don't want to speak too much a little
wood this is real wood
i don't want to speak too much but you
haven't seen too many things happening
lately have you
he'll ban school choice charter schools
and pennsylvania opportunity
scholarships
in a second term i will provide school
choice
to every parent in america it's so
important
a vote for republicans is a vote for
safe communities
great jobs and a limitless future for
all americans and in conclusion and i
love being back with you in pennsylvania
so many incredible memories certainly
not so many what a night that was
remember that night
donald trump has won the commonwealth
of pennsylvania
[Applause]
remember how late they just didn't want
to call it they didn't want to call it
i said call it already if i lost we were
at 98
we were substantially ahead if i lost
every single vote we still won
it took them like till 2 o'clock in the
morning before they called in the
meantime wisconsin came
in michigan came in but they just
refused to call pennsylvania they just
couldn't remember they were crying and
they were all screwed up
over the next four years we'll make
america into the manufacturing
superpower of the world
and we'll end our reliance on china once
and for all that's already happening
[Music]
we'll hire more police increased
penalties for assault on law enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
that people don't want
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms your
second amendment
we'll strike down terrorists who
threaten our citizens
and we will keep america out of endless
foreign ridiculous wars
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
and we will ensure peace through
strength and by the way we've rebuilt
our military i told you 2.5 trillion
dollars we have
weapons and equipment the likes of which
no country has ever seen before
we are the envy of russia we are the
envy of china
we are the envy of everybody there is no
country
that has what we have and i will tell
you when i first came here
one of our generals highly overrated
said to me sir
we have no ammunition that's where we
started and now we have the greatest
weapons anywhere in the world
and just hope to god we never have to
use them
we will end surprise medical building
require
price transparency which is already
signed january first of kicks in
and further reduce the cost of
prescription drugs and i'm talking about
50
60 70 80 percent because of what i've
done with favored nations
getting the lowest price mic the whole
world we're going down we're taking
these nations they pay a fraction of
what we pay i said nope
whatever they pay i want to pay why are
we paying more than any other nation
we're the highest we're going down to
match the lowest
the drug companies don't love me too
much just in case you
haven't heard we will strongly protect
medicare and social security
will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
america will land the first woman on the
moon and the united states will be the
first
nation to land an astronaut
on mars and we're very close
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students
and restore patriotic education to our
school
we will teach our children to love our
country
honor our history and always respect
our great american flag
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust
[Applause]
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people of
pennsylvania it's very important
so get your friends most important
election we've ever had
get your family get your neighbors and
get out and vote you got to get out and
vote like you'd never voted before
places that we won like erie places that
we won you got to get out and vote
because from erie to easton from
pittsburgh to harrisburg
and from allentown to right here in
johnstown
we stand on the shoulders of
pennsylvania patriots
who gave their blood sweat and tears
for this beloved nation
[Music]
this is the state where our founding
fathers declared
american independence think of what you
have in pennsylvania no think
who could say that this is it what
you've done here what
the history of this incredible place the
commonwealth of pennsylvania think of
what you've done
it's where the army weathered its brutal
winter at valley forge
and general george washington don't
worry
his statues are not coming down okay
let his men on a daring mission across
the delaware
and where our nation was saved by the
heroes of gettysburg
this is the place where generations of
tough
strong pennsylvania workers mine the
cold
work the railroads and forge the steel
that made america into the greatest and
most powerful nation
in the history of the world
and you have seen nothing yet
you wait do you see what we're doing
when you see what we're doing
we are making our country greater than
ever
before proud citizens like you helped
build this country
and together we are taking back our
country
we are returning power to you the
american people
with your help your devotion and your
drive we are going to keep on working
we are going to keep on fighting and we
are going to keep on
winning winning winning
[Applause]
and when you're a great congressman to
come to see me right
this great what a group of warriors i
don't know with them i'm not sure i can
handle that group
but when they come in to see me in the
oval office they say mr president
pennsylvania's not used to winning this
much we got to slow it down a little bit
and i'll say mike i'm sorry mike you
tell the rest of them mike we're not
going to slow it down at all
pennsylvania wants to win more than
anybody
in this country wants to win
pennsylvania is going to win
we're never going to stop we're going to
keep on winning
we're going to win so much you're going
to love every moment of it all right
hey you know what you lost long enough i
can tell you that many years where your
factories and your plants left because
we had stupid leadership
don't kid yourself you lost for a long
time and now you're winning and you're
winning
like never before open it up governor
open it up
because we're one movement one family
one people and one glorious nation under
god
and together with the incredible people
of pennsylvania
we have made america wealthy again
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
and we will make america safe again
and we will make america great again
thank you very much pennsylvania thank
you get out and vote
vote boat boat
[Music]
cause you're in a new town there's no
[Music]
later and i'll show you
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
are you listening to me
[Music]
[Music]
does it all by himself
[Music]
is
[Music]
i felt
someone came up to me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
say
[Music]
[Music]
listen to
do me want to be
[Music]
you
blue
[Music]
music
[Music]
dancing in the sand
[Music]
always with me
tiny dancing in my hand
[Music]
out in the
[Music]
she just left
is not that bad
[Music]
she sings the song
[Music]
and you can hear me
and i say softly
[Music]
[Music]
slowly
[Applause]
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
music
[Music]
you must see them
[Music]
[Music]
in my hand
[Music]
lying here
[Music]
when i say softly
[Music]
slowly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
today
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
he took
[Music]
drugs he took the midnight
[Music]
a singer in a snow care room
[Music]
it goes on and on and on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's
[Music]
you